all embraced and we all started crying
we're gonna need the tissues for this
one between tom holland andrew garfield
and toby maguire there are plenty of
emotional moments to go around on the
sets of the spider-man films these are
the scenes that made our favorite web
heads teary-eyed
number one peter may be forgotten but he
will always be loved one of the
emotional moments at the climax of no
way home was the conversation between
doctor strange and peter at the top of
the statue of liberty strange tells
peter that he loves him and that
everyone who loves him will forget who
he is benedict cumberbatch actually
improvised this emotional moment i came
up with this idea of to show that i love
him i didn't want him to make the
sacrifice of being forgotten the two
actors left their emotions flowing the
scene and made us in the audience feel
their shared pain me as an actor the
thing that matters most is that
emotional connection to a character
number two seeing all three spider-man
together was a magical moment the
rooftop scene when the spider-man all
meet for the first time was actually
rewritten at least 10 times according to
writers eric summers and chris mckenna
it's one of the most impactful and
emotional scenes in the movie and
filming it took an emotional toll on tom
holland you know when you make these big
movies it can take two days to shoot a
scene i've been crying for days on end
number three a reunion that was long
overdue toby maguire and alfred molina
first shared the screen together in
spider-man 2 all the way back in 2004 17
years later the two reunited for no way
home and as you can imagine things got
emotional the scene when they reunite
was very powerful for both of them and
their acting was genuine i got very
teary in that scene molina described how
his reunion with maguire was delightful
and emotional at the same time and how
they joked about being too old now i
think i said something like i'm
terrified that i might be a bit too old
for this
it's it gets harder and harder to to
deal with that number four this scene
was happy tears who didn't get choked up
at the end of no way home when all the
spider-man said their final goodbyes tom
holland andrew garfield and toby mcguire
all loved the time they spent together
on set and it felt like a dream come
true for all of them the hug they all
shared was actually written into the
script after the director and writers
saw the three actors embrace and start
crying together on their own it was the
perfect way to show how much the
spider-man meant to each other both in
the film and in real life yep that's how
we're gonna end the film
number five the redemption is real
andrew garfield's peter catching
zendaya's mj was an incredible moment
full of raw emotions and that wasn't
lost on the two actors they had an
amazing time shooting the scene and it
was actually the first thing the two
shot together i met you yesterday thanks
for catching me how are you you good
okay you have to cry sorry it was a
scene that completed an arc started
seven years ago during the amazing
spider-man 2 and it was a cathartic
experience for both the audience and the
actors it's pretty intense it went like
that and then suddenly we were kind of
done number six is this the end tom
zendaya and jacob all cried together
after filming their last scene of no way
home because it felt like it could be
the last time all three of them would be
together for the spider-man films we
were definitely treating no way home
like it was coming to an end and it felt
like it in a way it is like things are
coming to an end as director john watts
explained that no way home was the last
movie in the homecoming trilogy and that
the next story would be very different
it would be heartbreaking if we never
got to see these three together again it
was heartbreaking but also really
exciting because we're all moving into
the next chapter of our careers i don't
think i've cried like that ever
so it's been incredible it's been
honestly the best thing that's ever
happened to me number seven this may be
the saddest scene in spider-man history
aunt may's passing was a huge emotional
plot point in no way home and it was
very emotional to film tom holland felt
a special connection between his
character and mate the relationship
between me and marissa throughout these
films has been really integral to the
heart and soul of the story not only did
we have to say goodbye to aunt may but
it was also a goodbye to marissa tomei
who means so much to everyone who worked
on the movies shout out to aunt may
number eight mr stark none of us feel
good after this scene tom holland's
infamous i don't wanna go scene in
infinity war was actually improvised by
holland tom has a specific routine he
does before he needs to shoot an
emotional crying scene he repeats a word
or phrase over and over again until he
becomes emotional in this case it was
the i don't want to go line which is why
it feels so real and visceral on screen
i don't want to go you don't want to go
please we had so much fun on those sets
but when we got into the emotion of that
moment we really dived into it
number nine we love these three together
andrew garfield got emotional on the set
of no way home simply because he got to
be on set with tom holland and toby
maguire far too old to be playing
spider-man now but they they asked me
back the sweetest thing ever he loved
the role he played in the movie acting
as an older brother mentor figure to the
younger tom holland spider-man while
also being a younger brother in awe of
toby maguire's older spidey the three
worked incredibly well together and
their love for each other was very real
we can't imagine anyone else in these
roles we kind of feel things in each
other we challenge things in each other
number ten this one is all about
positive emotions all three spider-man
actors were very happy and emotional to
be all together sharing the screen and
garfield felt as if they really had a
loving brotherly bond this love spilled
over onto the screen as andrew garfield
improvised his i love you guys line that
was just me loving them this is what
makes their chemistry unrivaled their
affection for each other will always
make us smile honestly mate it was the
most incredible experience of my career
number eleven we get claustrophobic just
thinking about this one the scene where
peter is trapped under rubble and
spider-man homecoming was very intense
and very real tom holland revealed that
the rubble he was under was actually
real cement and debris that was
extremely heavy it was on wires and they
would just slowly lift off but i
couldn't lift it myself it was too heavy
pollen had to climb in and out from
under the cement blocks between tapes
which he described as brutal maybe next
time they should just use styrofoam
blocks instead
number 12 he should have gone for the
catch gwen's fall and ultimate demise in
the amazing spider-man 2 was the most
powerful scene of the short-lived
franchise it was a difficult scene for
andrew garfield to film due to all the
emotions he felt remember at the time he
was dating co-star emma stone which made
the scene a little too real absolutely
horrid i don't want to think about it
it's the worst your body doesn't know
it's not real poor andrew emma stone
however had a completely different
perspective on the scene as she stated
she was morbidly looking forward to it
with great power comes great emotion we
get teary-eyed just watching these
scenes so we can only imagine what it
was like to actually be on set filming
them we're gonna need our web shooters
to swip over some tissues which
spider-man scene makes you the most
emotional let us know down in the
comments and thanks for stopping by at
the things